we were actually talking about um like
at some point the media and so i pulled
up this tweet from glenn greenwald i
have no idea when
i was planning on segwaying to this but
we went to game of thrones would have
been real
so anyway let's just rewind and then
segway to this
uh tweet from glenn greenwald absolutely
yes so uh glenn's great he tweeted
however shockingly tiny and minuscule
you think
msnbc and cnn's audience sizes it's way
smaller than even that msnbc barely has
an audience on the weekends
i'm concerned their ratings are going to
fall into negatives
which shouldn't be possible i just love
the absolute
snark from glendon
so uh how many viewers do you think
msnbc gets at
8 p.m on what is it what is this uh
sunday
like how many how many viewers you think
okay primetime show not good i'm gonna
go
into a couple hundred six million six
million
is that too many wow that's so generous
check this out um fox news total viewers
is 1.2 million
sunday at 8 pm life liberty in levin 124
000 viewers
between the ages of 25 and 54.
that means most of their viewers like
1.1 million
are over the age of 54. cnn
gets 473 000 viewers above the age of 50
55 and older and only 78 000
25 to 54. and msnbc
gets 49 000 people in the key demo
you know what's crazy is we don't even
do a show that day and our clips do
better than
my crappy reality tv shows
destroyed these people and that was back
in the day
wow wow how pathetic
why did they like have so much power who
is propping them up
who's the puppet now i'm trying to
figure it out i'm feeling pretty good
you should but you should also feel
pretty scared
scared they're gonna come for you no i
it's like
um what was i like they're a withered
and drying
you know like husk yeah let's like hey
i'm going to destroy you and i'm like
like dark
crystal like yeah they're they're sexy
suck out
life force it's like yeah or
watch dark crystal am i ages ago yeah
and i was like
so oh but i saw lord of the rings so
they're like smeagol
yes and the precious is their ring and
and we got it we we
we have the views it's more
decentralized you know there's a bunch
of different
channels that get tons of views but what
you know you know it's amazing
key demographic this is the main issue
right so almost all the viewers for fox
msnbc and cnn are 55 and older
no disrespect to them but what do you
think that means in 10 20 years
yeah yeah they're they're they're done
it's over
well that's why uh all the
big tech is trying so hard because they
know that they've brainwashed all these
children and that
tick tock is where they get their news
we're so
pathetic we're on tick-tock yep i am not
on tick-tock
we got clips going up on tick-tock
really yeah so uh
i thought that's kami chyna stuff what
are you doing
fighting back on the battlefield i guess
so we we put up we put up clips
everywhere
and i don't blame you if we can put
clips up from this show on platforms
like tick tock
good then the younger people who are
there i actually think it's mostly older
people
to be completely honest but maybe not
completely there's a lot of older people
on it
are there filters i don't know oh like
those
beauty filters that's where all old
chicks like me were like oh hey
i'm 22 again we should put a clip up
with beauty filters one day yeah
we i was thinking about this you know a
lot of people have been like tim why
won't you quit youtube because they're
censoring people and i'm like
it's a massive battlefield why would we
give up ground that we didn't lose yet
you know people ask me all the time
while i'm still on facebook
because i say things they're like how
are you still here i'm like don't know
for one and for two i like built this
crap
i don't want to lose it you build
something you don't want to just bounce
ride it into the ground darling yeah i
mean we're setting up the website
yeah hiring people to do news fully
expecting youtube will eventually give
us the boot
yeah but until until then let's use as
leverage as much as we can from these
networks and keep pushing back
otherwise just like walking away come on
youtube
it's tim cass they're good folks
i actually think it's bigger than that i
think that we need to make conservatism
and these good right-wing ideas cool
and that means putting them on platforms
like tick tock they are
cool that's why all the punk rockers and
weirdos like us
are like on the side now we are the cool
ones
did you did you see bad religion do that
like weird pro
alt-right song no i every time people
afford me these cringy songs they're
like you're gonna love it i'm like yeah
i know i have a life
and then i don't watch it if there's a
cat that's it's on
or a chicken check it out like the ra
the reason the ratings are in the gutter
for for msnbc worse than cnn is that
they they they excised their legitimate
audience
for orange man bed they were so
desperate to get ratings that they were
like let's keep saying trump sucks
well let's say you know a few years ago
they had a hundred thousand key demo
viewers
and 75 000 are rational moderate people
like us
they went so insane they lost all of
them but they gained
half a million to a million trump
derangement syndrome people now that
trump is gone
their whole brand was we're the
anti-trump there's no one left to watch
with no trump
these punk rockers it's the same thing
for decades you've had you have some
bands
who have built themselves up like we are
the anti-establishment the war machine
is bad
yeah and then all of a sudden they find
themselves on the winning side
they find themselves saying the same
things as walmart.com
and they're like if we come out and say
they're wrong
our audience that we've built will hate
us
you know what i was kind of scared when
i started
saying things and you know what i got
every libertarian and conservative
person
just came and bought avon for me and i'm
like what
is going on like dudes dudes we have bug
guards so everyone's buying
spf and this and that i'm like this is
amazing so yeah i got canceled by the
left
and my my fellow i guess patriots
are very supportive i'm sure you guys
are finding that out it was the exact
opposite of what i thought was going to
happen
and then they can't fire me because i'm
independent and all they want to do is
fire me so we we went to a skate park
somebody somebody super chatted at us
they were like tim go to wakefield skate
park it's like in the dc area
so we went there and first of all let me
just say like wow that it's falling
apart
like the ramps are collapsing and i'm
like some little kid's gonna fall
anyway there was graffiti and it said
black lives matter
like some some young teenage kids
skating at a skate park
were like i'm going to vandalize
property with the corporate message from
amazon.com
starbucks made me do it yeah right it
was like the weirdest thing i was like
imagine you go to the skate park on like
some kids like he walks up to
he's got spray paint he's like
walmart.com and i'm like
okay dude we were all like you know it
would be cool
that's spray paint tool yeah a tool
kicks ass
you know i'm sorry people use like that
people just do like vandalize
like to break to do do damage i mean a
lot of kids would like spray paint a
name or something
but you typically would go to the skate
park and they would write swear words
and draw dicks and stuff like that don't
you miss the days where people watch
beavis and butt head and we had to worry
about kids laying
in oncoming traffic on the highway that
to me was way more peaceful and better
than what's happening now
what happened i encourage you internet
the internet like displayed some some
the truth of what humanity is
the mask has slipped we're all
sociopaths you know you know what i was
thinking about i was thinking about this
i'm like i'm 35 man
i just don't understand these kids these
days i know right like there was there
would never be
no but like when i was 15 like i would
go
and and be like that thing i saw on the
tv about us holding hands
that's what i'm going to spray paint we
were just spray painting dicks we
weren't raised on our phones i didn't
have a cell phone
until i was 21 years old and i moved to
new york city
after i won top model so i didn't have
this like
oh it's my phone and every moment in my
phone like it is pretty cool
but you could put it down i heard that
babies
are being born with their necks arced
forward from people staring down at
their phones this could be they're
getting spurs
in their necks the babies the new yeah
creation of human is
is being born different because of the
way people stand i've heard
next spurs okay unplugged dude it's the
borg
you know the board from start that
happens fast you always say borg i feel
like we're
it's a zerg like someone's kerrigan the
popper
puppet masters like starcraft yeah no
the the borg has a queen who is like
who is hierarchically above all of the
rest of the world i respect
track i was never into dessert it's also
the but but here here's the the general
story of the borg is that they were a
regular humanoid race
who started incorporating different
medical technologies into themselves
cybernetics
until they linked their brains and then
instantly became a hive they could hear
everything all at once and they worked
in unison and all of their minds became
one mission
and we got these kids they're on these
phones and they're getting the corporate
messages and they're like yes
yes spray paint corporate message dude
you want to talk about being in the
matrix if one agent sees you
and then everyone else knows that you're
there that's like the mind
can mind me it's like uh so uh you know
luke right he's been on the show yes
he was in we were in germany together
and someone saw him in a photograph like
he was like walking a different
direction from someone else and so they
accused him of
being a nazi what he's walking down the
street
and then someone points at him and yells
nazi and then random people
get up run up to him start punching him
and beating him and this other guy max
like
this random german journalist max who's
like just a regular guy
these people just get up out of nowhere
and it's like you're saying like the
agents one agent sees you and then all
of a sudden the other people just like
turn into agents
and then start attacking you that's like
what it is i wish they'd do that to
pedophiles
bad people never get punished they're
like buy them learjets and give them
money and i'm like wait a minute
and then luke's just hanging out and
they all and the anchor person
on tv goes that's a conspiracy theory
oh okay you're like hey look at the
story but this guy and then they're like
you're a conspiracy theorist
that's not true i'm so tired of humanity
can i be honest with you guys
yeah everyone out there i hate 95
of you i'm bilbo baggins on my property
i have the sign that says we don't want
any more visitors
well-wishers or distant relations like
get away so this is bilbo after
returning from defeating where he's like
i just want to see mountains again i
hate these people he was traumatized
i mean billboard he was surrounded by
simpletons he's like they haven't even
seen the world like most americans
yeah we've seen the world yeah i mean i
lived and worked in south africa i
almost died in russia i lived out of
italy and worked on a visa where
same thing in france i mean these people
have
all these big opinions on the world in
america and they haven't gone anywhere
i saw it once on instagram it's like
okay
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you